les faits se sont produits vers 14h20 ce
vendredi 23 avril au commissariat de
rambouillet et plus précisément au
niveau du sas du bâtiment d'après une
source policière
la fonctionnaire âgée d'une quarantaine
d'années et mère de deux enfants étaient
sortis pour changer son disque de
stationnement
elle se retrouve alors aux côtés de
l'assaillant qui lui assène deux coups
de couteau réaction immédiate de ses
collègues policiers à l'accueil qui ont
neutralisé l'individu et porté secours
aussitôt à leurs collègues qui étaient
en situation d'arrêt cardio-ventilatoire
et malgré l'intervention des pompiers la
fonctionnaire est décédé le premier
ministre jean castex s'est rendu sur
place en compagnie du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin
mes premières pensées vont à la famille
de cette fonctionnaire et à tous ses
proches
je me suis rendu immédiatement sur place
avec gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur pour apporter tout notre
soutien aux policiers et fonctionnaires
du commissariat de rambouillet
comme vous l'imaginez très durement
éprouvées par ces faits et je tiens à
rendre hommage aux fonctionnaires de
police qui ont immédiatement neutralisé
l'auteur des faits je voudrais dire à
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français
combien notre détermination à lutter
contre le terrorisme sous toutes ses
formes est plus que jamais intact a
gravement blessé par balle l'assaillant
est également décédée de nationalité
tunisienne il était âgé de 36 ans
inconnu des services de renseignement
l'homme était arrivé en france en 2009
le parquet national anti terroriste
s'est saisi de l'enquêté
les raisons de cette saisine sont les
suivantes en premier le déroulement même
des faits qui comprend des éléments de
repérage également réalisation d'effets
modalités mêmes du crime la personne de
la victime mais aussi les propos tenus
par l'auteur au moment de la réalisation
des faits il s'ensuit une enquête qui
est ouverte des chefs d'assassinât
contre personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste
ainsi que d'associations de malfaiteurs
choristes de criminels aux côtés des
deux ministres sur place également des
élus locaux comme valérie pécresse la
présidente de la région ile de france
pierre bédier le président du
département des yvelines qui n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer à notre micro
il a réagi par voie de communiqué de
presse que nous allons vous proposer
dans un instant mais on écoute d'abord
valérie pécresse suivi des autres
réactions locales
on a voulu frapper là encore un symbole
de la france parce que nos policiers
sont la france ils sont le visage de la
france et on a cherché aussi à à
déstabiliser le pays en venant ici
s'attaquer aux forces de police dans
cette ville si tranquille du sud rural
de l'île de france et un quartier
tranquille c'est une ville tranquille
ce sont des fonctionnaires de police qui
font leur métier de manière absolument
exemplaire au quotidien ils savent que
chaque jour potentiellement ils peuvent
mettre leur vie en jeu mais là rien rien
évidemment ne laissait présager un tel
drame pour une fonctionnaire à une
unique at-il l'infamie terroriste
s'attaque de nouveau à notre communauté
nationale lâchement en choisissant une
symbolique puissante une femme policière
dans un commissariat
c'est une nouvelle épreuve pour la
france et pour les français j'apprends
avec effroi l'assassinât d'une
fonctionnaire de police du commissariat
de rambouillet cette ville qui m'est si
chère une victime de plus du terrorisme
islamiste
je vais exprimer tout mon soutient la
famille de la victime ainsi qu'à ses
collègues policiers
encore une fois durement touchés plus
que jamais nous devons être à leurs
côtés véronique matillon maire de
rambouillet le conseil municipal les
rambolitains la communauté nationale ont
appris l'assassinât d'une agent de
police au commissariat de rambouillet la
ville est en deuil leurs pensées vont à
la famille et aux policiers un
représentant yvelinois d'un syndicat de
police que nous avons joint par
téléphone s'est dit abasourdi par cette
attaque
survenu dans une circonscription de
rambouillet à l'accoutumée très calme le
département des yvelines une nouvelle
fois touché par la folie terroriste
quelques années après l attaque de
magnanville et plus récemment
l'assassinât du professeur samuel pâti à
conflans sainte honorine